[Musik]
[Applaus]
eine vfahre gespielt durch die durch ein
Ensemble der Gard Musik hat den 11 Tag
der whrpflicht eröffnet und wir freuen
uns sehr die Kameraden haben gerade noch
am bal der offizere in der Hofburg
gespielt und schon sind Sie hier wieder
einsatzbereit so wie auch viele von uns
die wir hier uns eingefunden haben ich
darf ganz herzlich begrüßen und
einleiten und ganz besonders
begrüßen die
Präsidenten die Funktionäre die
Mitglieder all jener Organisationen die
die Plattform wehrhaftes Österreich
bilden diese Plattform hat in der
werrpflichtdebatte 2010 beginnen sich
eingesetzt für die Beibehaltung der
werpflicht in Österreich hat bei der
volksbefagung am 20 jän 2013 diesen
volminanten Erfolg mit verursacht wenn
man so möchte und seit damals feiern wir
am 20 diesen Tag der werrpflicht als
Manifestation des whrwillens in
Österreich und ich darf daher
stellvertretend für alle Präsidenten und
Funktionäre die Präsidenten unserer
bundesweiten und größten
Mitgliedsorganisationen begrüßen
Block meinen stellvertretenden
Vorsitzenden Generalmajor Nikolaus Egger
von der Vereinigung Österreichischer
biskeeper den Präsidenten des
österreichischen Kameradschaftsbundes
Bundesrat außerdienst Ludwig Bieringer
den Obmann der Interessensgemeinschaft
der Berufsoffiziere Oberst sigfed Albel
und für die österreichische
unteroffiziersgesellschaft wizeleitnant
Richard Knaus und unseren
Generalsekretär der diesen heutigen
nachmittagsevent organisiert hat mit
seinem Team Herr Generalmajor dr Peter
Fender herzlich willkommen und danke für
euer
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Engagement
[Applaus]
wir repräsentieren zwar bereits etwa
250.000 Mitglieder in Österreich aber
nicht alle werpitischen Vereine sind
Teil unserer Plattform trotzdem auch
viele hier und so darf ich
kameradschaftlich und freundschaftlich
auch die Funktionäre der anderen Vereine
begrüß begrüßen beispielsweise das
stratch das Kuratoriums umfassende
Landesverteidigung die hochen
Deutschmeister die österreichische
Gesellschaft für whmedizin und
whfarmazie und und und viele noch mehr
herzlich willkommen liebe
[Applaus]
Kameraden heiß umfedet wild umstritten
liegst dem Erdteil du in Mitten einem
starken Herzen gleich so heißt es in der
zweiten Strophe der österreichischen
Bundeshymne und wenn man diese Metapher
mit dem Herzen heranzieht
dann ist auch klar dass wenn andere
Regionen des Körpers ein Problem haben
irgendwann auch das Herz ein Problem
haben
wird und wenn andere Regionen des
Körpers verletzt werden wird es Einfluss
auf das Herz haben und vor diesem
Hintergrund haben wir uns gedacht den
Kontinent Europa ins Augenmerk der
heutigen Veranstaltung zu legen die
Peripherie um unser Herz um
herauszukristallisieren welche Einflüsse
auf dieses Europa einwirken und welche
Auswirkungen das umgekehrt auch wieder
auf Österreich haben kann und haben
wird daher steht also das Motto des
heutigen Tages Ring of Fire
Herausforderungen Europas und dazu haben
wir es geschafft ein tatsächlich
höchstkaretiges Podium einzuladen und
hierher zubringen dass die Aufgabe
übernommen hat dieses ausleuchten dieses
Themas vorzunehmen und bitte begrüßen
Sie mit mir und ich stelle en Block vor
das Podium der heutigen Veranstaltung
zuerstm den Chef des österreichischen
Generalstabes general Rudolf Striedinger
der die österreichische Perspektive
einbringen wird
anschließend Generalleutnant Steven
bchem den stellvertretenden Kommandanten
der US-Truppen in
Europa im Anschluss Kapitän zur See Lars
Schümann den stellvertretenden
kabinettsdirektor des militärausschusses
der EU und damit auch ein ganz enger
Mitarbeiter
unseres general Brieger der sie alle
auch ganz herzlich grüßen lässt und Last
B not least den der wird dann auch den
ersten Auftakt geben Brigadier Walter
Feichtinger der so das Lagebild den
krisenbogen den Ring of fireire hier für
uns skizzieren wird heißen wir dieses
Podium
willkommen
[Applaus]
ein spannendes Thema und ein exzellentes
Pendel hat nicht nur diesen festsal der
industriellen Vereinigung gefüllt den
großen wie wahrscheinlich auch parallel
dazu den kleinen bei dieser Gelegenheit
auch herzlichen Dank an die
Industriellenvereinigung die uns seit
Jahren diesen Raum oder diese Räume für
die Veranstaltung zur Verfügung
stellt dieser dieses
spannende Thema wird auch in einem
Livestream äh auf Youtube übertragen
bleibt dort auch erhalten sie können
also auch alles nachlesen bei dieser
Gelegenheit auch herzliches Willkommen
an die Gäste im Internet aber wir haben
auch durch dieses exzellente Podium das
spannende Thema viele viele
Ehrengäste anlocken können äh und ich
freue mich an der Spitze die dieser
ehrenäste unsere Frau Bundesminister
Claudia Tanner herzlich begrüßen zu
dürfen zum fünften Mal in Folge hier und
sie wird auch wieder großworte sprechen
herzlich willkommen Frau
Ministerin besonders respektvoll
begrüßen wir den Botschafter der
Republik Türkei seine Exzellenz öern se
herzlich willkommen
und in Vertretung des Herrn
Bürgermeister und Landeshauptmann von
Wien darf ich begrüßen Herrn
Landtagsabgeordneten und Oberleutnant
Markus Schober herzlich
[Applaus]
willkommen ein ganz herzliches Grüß Gott
entbitte ich dem hochwürdigen Herrn
Militärbischof dr Werner Freistetter
[Applaus]
gemeinsam und zugleich auch
stellvertretend für alle aktiven und
ehemaligen Mitglieder der gesetzgebenden
Körperschaften begrüße ich den
Vorsitzenden des
landesverteidigungsausschusses im
Nationalrat hern Abgeordneten zum
Nationalrat Magister Volker Reifenberger
oberstleutnand sowie die weiteren
Vorsitzenden der parlamentarischen
bundeswehrkommission Abgeordneten zum
Nationalrat Magister Fritz ofenauer und
Abgeordneter zum Nationalrat Robert
Leimer herzlich willkommen mein
[Applaus]
Herr ich begrüße ganz herzlich die
Leiterin der präsidialsektion im
Bundesministerium für Landesverteidigung
Magister Elisabeth kckis und den
Sektionschef im Ministerium für Arbeit
und Wirtschaft Herr Magister Georg KZ
herzlich
[Applaus]
kommen aus der Generaldirektion
Landesverteidigung im Bundesministerium
für Landesverteidigung freue ich mich
den Leiter der Direktion 3
Generalleutnant Erik sitkoovwiics und
die Leiterin der Direktion 8 brigadiier
dr Silvia Sperandio herzlich begrüßen zu
[Applaus]
dürfen
weiters begrüße ich den Vorsitzenden der
bundesheergewerkschaft Herrn Magister
Walter hirch herzlich
willkommen mein kameradschaftlicher Gruß
gilt de milizbeauftragten der V
Bundesminister Generalmajor Magister
Erwin hameser herzlich
[Applaus]
willkommenlreiche ausländischer
Streitkräfte sind der Einladung gefolgt
und so darf ich an der Spitze begrüßen
Major General Gregory kN den
Kommandanten der Vermont National Guard
unseres Partners im State partnership
Programm welcome
[Musik]
general und stellvertretend für die
anwesendenaches darf ich ganz herzlich
begrüßen den do der agredierten
verteidigungsmilit und luftatchees aus
der Schweiz oberstem Generalstab Urs
Sulser
[Applaus]
sowie die Anwesenden attaches aus
Finnland Frankreich Lettland Rumänien
Spanien dem Vereinigten Königreich und
den Vereinigten Staaten von
[Applaus]
Amerika herzlich begrüße ich den
teritorialen Kommandanten
Militärkommandant von Wien Magister Kurt
brigadiermister Kurt Wagner und den
Militärkommandanten von Niederösterreich
Oberst Michael Lippert sowie die
Kommandanten der dritten jägerbgade
Brigadier Christian habersat und den
Kommandanten der S jägerbgade Brigadier
Horst Hofer herzlich
[Applaus]
willkommen und abschließ darf ich
stellvertretend für alle Soldaten des
Ruhe und
reservestandes hervorragende Vertreter
der Vergangenheit unseres
österreichischen Bundesheers begrüßen
die Generale Karl meizen Horst bleiner
Ernest König und Edmund endacher
herzlich willkommen sehr geehrte Herren
[Applaus]
generale und damit darf ich bereits
überleiten und der Frau Minister den
Raum freigeben für die Grußworte noch
mal herzlich willkommen Frau
[Applaus]
Bundesminister hochwürdiger Herr Militär
Bischof ihre
Exzellenz Generäle aus dem Innland und
Ausland
Kommandanten Soldatinnen
Soldaten sehr geehrter Herr Präsident
ich glaube ich kann sie alle mit Fug und
Recht ansprechen als die Lobby unseres
Heeres die Lobby in unseres Heeres die
sie in Wahrheit auch in Zeiten waren als
wir uns alle auf einer Insel der Seligen
gefühlt haben da spreche ich zum einen
von der
Volksabstimmung nun mehr 11 Jahren am 20
jänar 2013 da spreche ich aber auch
davon dass wir uns so sicher gefühlt
haben dass wir vermeinten das
österreichische Bundesheer bräuchte
weder die entsprechenden finanziellen
Mittel noch die entsprechende
Unterstützung darüber hinaus wir haben
nicht das gemacht was eigentlich in der
Verfassung steht nämlich unsere
Neutralität mit allen uns zur Verfügung
stehenden Mitteln zu
verteidigen das österreichische
Bundesheer hat denn noch immer immer
alle seine Anforderungen
erfüllt trotz dieser nicht verhandenen
Mittel sei es im Bereich der
assistenzanforderungen wenn um
Katastrophen gegangen ist im Inland und
ja Herr Botschafter auch im Ausland als
dieses Furch
Erdbeben die Türkei erschüttert hat das
war die ganze Zeit überb so damit wir
jetzt auf den richtigen Weg gekommen
sind das ist nicht zuletzt ihnen allen
zu verdanken das ist dieser Plattform zu
verdanken das ist jedem und jeder
einzelnen von ihnen zu verdanken die
sich eingesetzt haben für das
österreichische Bundesheer und für ein
Konzept das auch schon in Vergessenheit
Gerat ist obwohl es in der Verfassung
steht nämlich die umfassende
Landesverteidigung dazu leisten sie alle
und haben sie alle den entsprechenden
Beitrag geleistet wir haben gemeinsam
eine
Trendwende geschafft eine Trendwende zum
einen einmal was die Volksabstimmung
anbelangt hat ein so eindeutiges
Ergebnis für die Basis in Wahrheit des
gesamten
Bundesheeres und selbstverständlich für
die Miliz Herr
milizbeauftragter und wir haben auch
eine trennwende geschafft was das Budget
anbelangt ich bin nun über vier Jahre im
Amt und jede der Budgetverhandlungen hat
ein höheres Budget für das
österreichische Bundesheer gebracht aber
was uns sehr geehrte Herrn Abgeordnete
gemeinsam gelungen ist mit dem Beschluss
des
landesverteidigungsfinanzierungs
Gesetzes das werden wir wahrscheinlich
erst im Blick zurückerahnen können
nämlich eine Planbarkeit eine
Planbarkeit die über die nächste
Legislaturperiode hinausgeht die uns 18
Milliarden Euro alleine in den nächsten
vier Jahren zur Verfügung stellt die wir
sehr zielgerichtet investieren werden
wir haben einen grandiosen Aufbauplan
der genau die drei Bereiche aufzählt das
brauche ich Ihnen da gar nicht näher
erläutern und der reicht bis zum Jahr
2032 und darüber
hinaus wir werden diesen Plan umsetzen
mit Nachdruck umsetzen dazu brauchen wir
aber auch sie alle denn wenn wir jetzt
all diese Beschaffungen tätigen sei es
jetzt in der Luft mit unseren 66 neuen
Hubschraubern sei mit der Modernisierung
der panzerflotte mit allem was wir
geschützte Mobilität brauchen mit den
Investitionen auch in unsere
Pioniertruppe dann hilft uns das alles
nichts wenn wir nicht das entsprechende
Personal haben ich schaue hier auch
unsere beinah frisch gebackene
sektionschefin an das ist eine große
Verantwortung die wir hier tragen aber
auch in diesem Bereich hilft uns die
Wehrpflicht weil welches andere
Unternehmen kann schon pro Jahr auf über
16 000 junge Männer jetzt seit 1 April
auch Frauen mit dem freiwilligen
Grundwehrdienst zurückgreifen und die
während dieser Zeit begeistern für das
österreichische Bundesheer das werden
wir tun das werden wir gemeinsam tun
wenn wir das Budget haben die
entsprechenden Beschaffungen getätigt
haben das entsprechende Personal haben
dann sollten wir aber auch wissen was es
zu verteidigen gilt sprech da von der
geistigen Landesverteidigung es ist in
Vergessenheit geraten offensichtlich bei
dem einen oder anderen dass es keine
Selbstverständlichkeit ist in Frieden in
Freiheit leben zu können in einer
Demokratie auch leben zu können das
müssen wir den Kleinsten schon
beibringen oder wieder ans Herz legen
auch das haben wir gemeinsam geschafft
die geistige Landesverteidigung wird ab
nun ab dem Herbst des vergangenen Jahr
es wieder in den Schulen gelehrt lassen
wir es nicht mehr zu dass
Landesverteidigung am Kasernen Zaun
endet sondern schauen wir und sorgen wir
dafür dass Sie ein Platz findet in jedem
Betrieb am Ende des Tages in jeder
Familie nicht zum Selbstzweck sondern
zur Sicherheit von uns allen ich danke
Ihnen allen dass sie diesen Weg
mitgegangen sind in einer sehr
herausfordernden Zeit in einer
herausfordernden Zeit wo wir Krisen
kriegen gegenüber stehen wo es nur einen
Schlüssel gibt wie man dem begegnen kann
das ist der der Zusammenarbeit und daher
bin ich auch sehr glücklich über diese
Partnerschaft mit dem state partnership
program und ich ziehe meinen Hut vor
dieser besonderen
Einsatzbereitschaft general night der
hat um 4 Uhr in der Früh noch gesungen
ich darf das an dieser Stelle verraten
man sieht's ihm nicht an auch da sieht
man das ist mehr als nur eine
militärische Partnerschaft sie geht
darüber
hinaus das Bundesheer kann so viel von
der Musik über die Unterstützung unserer
heres
Leistungssportlerinnen und Sportler wir
dürfen aber eines nicht vergessen was
die wahre Kernaufgabe ist nämlich die
der militärischen Landesverteidigung und
auch in diesem Bereich haben wir
unglaublich viel aufzuholen auch das
werden wir tun alleine im Jahr 2024 über
200 Übungen die wir vorgesehen haben mit
einen sehr starken milizanteil natürlich
und eine große Übung die ich bereits im
Jahr
2022 beauftragt habe Schutzschild 24
denn auch das gehört dazu sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren Lobbyisten unseres
großartigen heres ich bitte sie gehen
Sie diesen Weg unserer Mission vorwärts
hin zu einer modernen Armee auch weiter
mit uns es lebe das österreichische
Bundesheer es lebe die Republik
[Applaus]
Österreich
herzlichen Dank an die Gade Musik und
ich darf nun Bri Walter frechtinger
ersuchen uns das Lagebild zu erläutern
Brig Feichtinger vorzustellen hieße
Eulen nach Athen tragen als langjähriger
Leiter des IFK an der
Landesverteidigungsakademie ist da für
seine Analysen bekannt geworden und er
hat es im setzt es im Ruhestand fort er
war auch schon bei einem Tag der
whrpflicht hier und hat eine ähnliche
Aufgabe gemeistert er wird es auch heute
mit Bravur tun lieber Walter herzlich
willkommen danke für deinen
Beitrag sehr geehrte Frau Bundesminister
sehr geehrte herr Präsident geschätzte
Damen und Herren ist mir natürlich schon
eine Ehre und Auszeichnung hier heute be
ihen das Lagebild darstellen zu dürfen
und ich liebe solche Aufträge wo es
heißt sag was über das Lagebild das ist
ein richtiger sattelbefehl wie die
Militärs sagen der Freiraum lässt und
ich werde versuchen diesen Freiraum in
den nächsten 20 Minuten zu nutzen ohne
ins Detail zu gehen ich gehe deswegen
nicht ins Detail weil das würde den
Zeitrahmen beweiten überschreiten wir
sind in sehr turbulenten Zeiten und das
was ich derzeit am meisten höre und
gefragt werde ist ich kann mir die
Nachrichten nicht mehr anschauen ich
drehe den Fernseher nicht mehr auf ich
lese die Zeitungen nicht mehr das ist ja
unglaublich was da abgeht und der
Eindruck ist nicht so täuschend das ist
keine Frage wir leben in sehr bewegten
Zeiten es tut sich sehr viel für mich
ist die Weltordnung im Umbruch ich werde
dazu dann ein bisschen reden und vor
allen es ist etwas was man im großen
Zusammenhang sehen muss sonst verlieren
wir uns im Detail wir füten uns zu Tode
ohne zu wissen dass es am nächsten Tag
eh schon wieder besser ausschauen könnte
und daher möchte ich Ihnen heute nicht
die Lust und die Laune nehmen ich möchte
sie auch nicht betrübt hinausgehen sehen
auf keinen Fall ich möchte einen Beitrag
dazu leisten das Bewusstsein vielleicht
ein bisschen zu schärfen umh Vorgänge
die man tagtäglich lieb erlebt oder
miterlebt oder auch in den Medien
mitbekommt ein bisschen zuordnen zu
können es ist keine Zeit für eine
Weltuntergangsstimmung aber ein gewisses
Bewusstsein muss man schon haben daher
habe ich mir erlaubt hier ein bisschen
die Weltlage zu machen und ich beginne
mit einem Lagebericht der eigentlich ein
Wetterbericht
ist das besser gut und zwar vier Punkte
möchte ich ansprechen wir haben eine
alte und eine neue Welt und ich sehe
sechs Arenen der Weltpolitik wo sich
diese Bruchlinien diese Spannungen
zwischen der alten und der neuen Welt
auftun dann muss man natürlich schon ein
bisschen schauen auf Europas Peripherie
ist ja unsere Umgebung bestimmt ja
unseren Alltag und dann der Versuch
eines kleinen Ausblicks wie kann es denn
tatsächlich weitergehen wel im
Umbruch vor zwei Jahren stand in einem
Bericht des
Verteidigungsministeriums wir haben ein
konfrontatives multipolares System ohne
zentrale Ordnungsmacht und allgemein
verbindliche
Ordnungsprinzipien was heißt das das ist
im Prinzip ein Freibrief für viele die
eigentlich die bestehende Ordnung und
das Ordnungssystem verändern wollen und
wenn wir nicht mehr die territoriale
Integrität von Staaten achten wenn das
gewaltsverbot nicht mehr geachtet wird
und wenn auch die Souveränität von
Staaten missachtet wird dann haben wir
ein Problem das ist genau dies ist nicht
beachten der internationalen Normen die
eigentlich für ein geteiliges
Zusammenleben weltweit sorgen sollen und
das ist die Frage wer sich heute noch
darum kümmert und da bin ich schon bei
der alten und bei der neuen Welt wir
haben hier sehr viele
Repräsentanten sie kennen Sie sicher
alle und ich bin sehr froh dass auch
eine Dame dabei ist we ansonsten hat man
ja wirklich den Eindruck schon fast dass
die Welt nur mehr von älteren Herren
geleitet wird und ganz wichtig es geht
fast immer um nationale Interessen
manchmal auch gepaart mit persönlichen
Ambitionen und wir reden oft von einer
Entschuldigung systemischen Rivalität
ich ich würde das ein bisschen anders
bezeichnen ich würde sagen wir haben
eigentlich Status qu Mächte und wir
haben revisionistische Mächte die mit
der heutigen Ordnung mit dem heutigen
Kräfteverhältnis und mächteverhältnis
nicht zufrieden sind und das ändern
wollen das ist ja auch ein gutes Recht
wenn man sagt 1945 wurde die heutige
Weltordnung festgelegt wir haben eine
dominierende Macht mit den USA wir haben
den sogenannten Westen der viele diese
dieser Regeln eigentlich bestimmt hat
bis zur Weltbank und bis zu all diesen
Institutionen die wir haben und es gibt
viele Staaten vor allem auch versammelt
im globalen Süden die damit unzufrieden
sind wir haben in Russland dass das
sicher nicht mehr so haben möchte wie
das bisher war wir haben aber auch China
als abstrebende Supermacht das heißt
Status Quo das sind wir und die
Revisionisten Mächte sind viele andere
die einfach hier neue Machtverhältnisse
schaffen
wollen damit bin ich schon bei den
Räumen wo sieht man denn das der
Indopazifik ist ja mittlerweile ein eine
sehr bekannte Region
über die viele Reden und wo auch eine
unglaubliche Dynamik ist und wenn wir
ins Südchinesische Meer schauen ich mach
den einen kleinen Blick hinein dann ist
dort unglaublich viel los aber nicht nur
im südkinesischen mer es geht eigentlich
von den Kurilen im Norden mit dem Streit
Japan gegen Russland bis hinunter weit
in den Süden wo man hier sagt da tut
sich was eine Region die immer mehr an
Beachtung auch gewinnt ist der die
Arktis wo man lange Zeit eigentlich kein
Militär haben wollte und gesagt hat
Sicherheit ist do kein Thema es geht nur
um Umwelt heute geht's auch um
Sicherheit wir haben eine dritte Region
das ist die Karibik Mittelamerika
Verbindung zwischen Nord und Süd und vor
allem es bringt die USA in eine völlig
neue Situation wenn plötzlich im Süden
des Landes eine mögliche potenzielle
Bedrohung auftauch
und die Insellage von der man viele
Jahre Sicherheit bezogen hat plötzlich
nicht mehr gegeben ist dann haben wir
undter sage ich eher pauschal den
afrikanischen Raum südlich der Sahara
und dann haben wir und wir kommen immer
näher nachuropa den eurasischen Raum die
Grenzstelle die Nahtstelle und wir haben
den M Raum Middle East nordfrica und in
diesen sechs Räumen zeigt sich genau
diese zunehmende Konkurrenz zwischen der
alten und der neuen Welt schauen
bisschen hinein in den
Indopazifik ich habe hier nicht den
ganzen Indopazifik aufgezeichnet aber
wir haben hier zwei unterschiedliche
Strategien das ist eine Rollback die
Chinesen wollen die Amerikaner hier aus
diesen Inselketten draußen haben und die
USA sind natürlich nach wie vor bestrebt
die Ordnung die sie nach 1945 aufgebaut
haben hier in der Region zu erhalten und
China einzudämmen und das mit möglichst
starken Verbündeten das ist diese Achse
und Speichen Strategie die man hier
schon über Jahrzehnte angewendet
hat hier noch im Detail die erste und
zweite Inselkette wo es wirklich darum
geht wenn die USA diese Inselketten
kontrollieren dann ist China einfach in
seiner strategischen militärischen
Ausdehung massiv eingeschränkt und das
ist das eine und Taiwan ist nur ein Teil
davon es geht um
mehr dazu braucht man auch immer
narrative weil man muss ja auch die
Gesellschaft abholen und auch in der
Politik erklären und da haben wir
einfach von shishing Ping z.B von
Asiaten für Asiaten auf gut deutsch da
hat keiner vom Westen was verloren und
wir hatten lange Zeit das
gegenküsteodell von den USA mittlerweile
geht es um die freie Fahrt auf den
Weltmeeren weil damit kann man natürlich
auch die Europäer entsprechend
überzeugen gehen wir gleich in die
artis durch die Veränderungen im Klima
durch den Klimawandel sind die Passagen
plötzlich immer mehr offen und wie immer
geht es natürlich um Kosten um Zugänge
und um die Kontrolle von entsprechenden
Bewegungslinien das hat dazu geführt
dass Russland viele Stützpunkte aus dem
Kalten Krieg und aus der Zeit D vor
sogar noch aktiviert hatte und hier
wirklich wieder eine enorme Kontrolle
aufbaut und nicht überrascht sein ich
weiß nicht wenn sie einm dort waren wenn
da Schnelle mal ein U-Boot auftaucht
auch das kann passieren hier nur die
Stützpunkte zu Erläuterung gehen wir
gleich ein bisschen weiter nach
Lateinamerika wie gesagt viele Jahre
Monro Doktrin der USA keiner kommt uns
zu nahe keiner kann sich bei uns hier
einmischen und wir halten uns dafür
woanders draußen gilt heute nicht mehr
china hat über viele Jahre hinweg hier
exzellente Beziehungen in die Region
aufgebaut und es geht natürlich um die
um die Verbindungslinie zwischen
Atlantik und Pazifik und da ist sehr
sehr viel Dynamik weil das hat natürlich
auch im Zusammenhang mit einer
stationierungsmöglichkeit in der Region
für die USA sehr heftige
Auswirkungen nur die wichtigsten Punkte
dazu der Hinterhof ist nach wie vor sehr
von Relevanz und das Öl aus Venezuela
ist gesamt geopolitisch
wirtschaftspolitisch auch nicht
uninteressant gehen wir gleich in die
Region 4 Afrika sie sehen hier einfach
wie sich die Wirtschaftsbeziehungen
innerhalb von wenigen Jahrzehnten
verändert haben wir haben auf der linken
Seite noch die alte Welt vor allem mit
Franzosen großbrit Europäern und auch
zum Teil Amerikanern und auf der rechten
Seite sehen wir wie plötzlich hier die
Handelsbeziehungen der meisten Staaten
mitina unglaublich zugenommen haben wir
wissen aber auch dass das eine Region
ist die von unglaublichen Turbulenzen
politischer Natur auch erfasst ist
Putsche in letzter Zeit in Mali und da
ist nicht unerheblich wenn man plötzlich
hier solche Elemente vom Wagner sieht
diese
söldninheiten den Herrn in der Mitte
gibt es nicht mehr aber es finden sich
immer Nachfolger in irgendeiner Form und
warum ich das erwähne ist weil es auch
alte gegen neue Ordnung ist wenn Sie es
schaffen mit einer kleinen
pschistentruppe in einem Land wie Mali
und 1500 wagnersoldaten dazu die
internationale Gemeinschaft aufus den
Land zu vertreiben die EU Mission zu
stoppen die unomission zu stoppen und
eigentlich den Einfluss den
stabilisierenden Einfluss des Westens
aus dem Land hinauszudringen dann ist
das aus unserer Perspektive natürlich
keine
positive es gibt auch einen anderen
Ansatz und ich darf hier zu ihnen
schauen Herr Botschafter es ist
er interessant welche softp die Türkei
mittlerweile in Afrika entwickelt hat
und das darf man nicht unterschätzen
weil Verkehrsverbindungen und heutzutage
Flugverbindungen sind unglaublich
wichtig und die Türkei hat hier
Großartiges geleistet indem sie fast in
alle Staaten hinein jetzt schon direkte
Flug Verbindungen hat das ist etwas was
wir in Europa überhaupt nicht haben
versuchen Sie mal nach Mali zu fliegen
ohne eine
heresmaschine damit näher an Europa
heran was haben wir denn in unserer
unmittelbaren Umgebung ich würde sagen
wir haben hier eine
integrationskonkurrenz was meine ich
damit wir haben ja die Zeit nach dem
Kalten Krieg wo viele Staaten in dieser
Pufferzone und ich verwende bewusst
diesen Begriff zwischen Russland und dem
da damaligen Europa sich neu orientiert
haben und sie hatten zweimal
Möglichkeiten Richtung Westen Westen
heißt Sicherheit mit der NATO und
wirtschaftliche Entwicklung mit der EU
oder Richtung Osten rassische
Wirtschaftsunion oder auch in die
militärverbund hineinzuk kommmen und
viele davon haben sich eben für den
Westen entschieden für diese beiden
Organisationen und diese
integrationskonkurrenz hat dazu geführt
dass Russland hier das eigentlich nicht
mehr so positiv mitgesehen hat wie es am
Anfang den Anschein hatte einer Schwäche
Russlands heraus und diese
integrationskonkurrenz ist nicht beendet
wenn wir heute jüngst Ansuchen von
Georgien und auch von Moldau bei der EU
um Aufnahme und bei der NATO Aufnahme
haben dann setzt sich diese
integrationskonkurrenz fort und es wird
weiterhin ein großer politischer
Streitpunkt zwischen Russland und dem
Westen
sein damit in dem
menum geht sich natürlich in den vollen
magreb also bis nach Marokko hinüber was
haben wir hier erinneren Sie sich noch
an den arabischen Frühling 2011
unglaublich welche positive Dynamik da
eigentlich hineingekommen ist und in
Wirklichkeit hat es in Krieg und Elen
geendet einzig Tunesien wo wir sagen das
könnte es noch irgendwie schaffen aber
wir haben in Ägypten Stabilität aber das
System eigentlich wieder vor wir haben
in Libyen derzeit gerade ein bisschen
Hoffnung W haben in Syrien nach wie vor
den Krieg nicht beendet und es ist im
Jemen auch nicht so und einige Staaten
in der Region fragen sich ob es auch in
der arabischen Frühling 2 geben wird
diese Entwicklung ist insoferne sehr
wichtig weil man aus der Erfahrung weiß
aus vielen Forschungsaktivitäten dass
Länder die von einem autoritären
totalitären System in Richtung
Demokratie versuchen zu transformieren
eigentlich schlechte Chancen haben 50%
schaffen es in der Regel nicht von den
restlichen 50% sind
25% die mühsam sich irgendwie in
Richtung Demokratie Rechtsstaat
weiterentwickeln und Einhaltung der
Menschenrechte und der anderen 25%
fallen eigentlich wieder zurück und wie
lange brauchen es die die schaffen 20
Jahre im Durchschnitt und wir haben 2011
wir schreiben heute
2024 das heißt hier darf man nicht kurz
fristig denken das ist eigentlich die
Botschaft selbstverständig volle
Unterstützung bei all diesen
Stabilisierung und
transformationsbemühungen aber nie
kurzfristig denken hier muss man in die
Zukunft schauen damit bin ich e schon
bei Europas Peripherie und beim Titel
Ring of Fire wenn sie Ring of Fire
eingeben kommen sie ganz wers hin
ja da mussen sie ein zweites mal googlen
dann um zu dieser Veranstaltung von
heute zu kommen z.B 40.000 km 500 km
breit 750 bis 900 aktive oder teilaktive
Vulkane aber wir haben auch einen Europa
mittlerweile einen Ring of Fire und hier
habe ich eine Grafik von Bertelsmann die
momentan eh sehr weit verbreitet ist aus
dem Jahre 2021 das heißt der Angriff auf
die Ukraine hat noch gar nicht
stattgefunden und den no sieht man hier
an diesen einzelen Flammen wie sich hier
eine Strecke ich würde sagen von 15 000
km und einer Breite von vielleicht 1000
km auch um Europa um das Europa was wir
drunter verstehen
herumdrängt wo man nie weiß wie viel
davon in nächster Zeit
hochgeht und das ist ein Status den wir
einfach zur Kenntnis nehmen müssen nicht
fürchten bringt überhaupt nichts zur
Kenntnis nehmen das ist unsere Umgebung
auf die müssen wir uns einstellen und
daher glaube ich sind in Europa zum Teil
ja die Zeichen der Zeit schon erkannt
worden und man versucht entsprechend
nachzuziehen ich kann es auch ein
bisschen anders darstellen wir haben
drei Regionen die wir hier im Europa
haben man könnte sagen die südliche
Region das ist Nordafrika und geht in
den Sahel hinein das ist eine Krise der
eine Zone der
Instabilität man weiß nie wie es
weitergeht man muss einfach damit
umgehen können was wir nah Osten derzeit
erleben ist natürlich eine Zone des ganz
heißen Krieges das ist unglaublich und
man hat den Eindruck dass du immer mehr
aufspringen und jetzt auch ein bisschen
schießen wollen ja zwischen Indien und
Pakistan z.B oder Iran und das ist
unvorstellbar Iran und Pakistan
natürlich aber ich glaube dass auch
schon die vernünftigen Kräfte hier
moderierend einwirken können Merkmal im
Nahen Osten um das nur kurz anzusprechen
wie stellt sich denn die Situation da
wir haben innerarabische Rivalitäten wir
haben die große Rivalität zwischen Iran
und Saudi-Arabien wir haben auch
Annährungsversuche
normalisierungsversuche zwischen Isel
und den arabischen Ländern und viele
erklären das losschlagen der Hamas und
auch der Hut ist jetzt damit dass sie
Angst haben vor dieser Annäherung dass
es hier zu einer Normalisierung kommt
und sie als die radikalen Elemente nicht
mehr die Unterstützung bekommen in
Zukunft die sie bisher hatten wenn dem
so ist dann kann man nur sagen hier
besteht wirklich große Hoffnung aber da
muss man jetzt einmal
durch noch einmal in einem anderen Bild
das gehen wir gar nicht ins Detail es
ist eine instabile Region mit heißen
Konflikten und was uns derzeit am
meisten bewegt ist natürlich die der
Beschuss der hutis das ist dieser Krieg
im gaserastreifen unvorstellbar wo sehr
unterschiedliche Vorstellungen sind was
dabei herauskommen s soll Syrien ist
noch lange nicht weg wir sehen welch
unglaubliche Zerstörung damit verbunden
ist und wir sehen hier immer wieder das
zündeln auch von der
hispal im im südlichen Libanon wo man
nie weiß steigen Sie jetzt voll ein oder
steigen Sie nicht voll ein in den Krieg
mit
Israel es war nur ein Teil der
Geschichte die eigentliche
Herausforderung zeige ich Ihnen am
Beispiel Ägypten die eigentliche
Herausforderung ist die Zukunft wenn Sie
eine Bevölkerung haben die noch immer
unglaublich zunimmt wenn sie von einem
schmalen Landstreifen leben das ist das
Niltal und das nilelta und davon nicht
mehr nutzbar wird durch die Versalzung
durch den steigenden Meeresspiegel dann
haben sie natürlich unglaubliche
politischen Druck und auch
gesellschaftlichen Druck wie hier die
Zukunft weitergeschehen kann und das ist
etwas was wir europäischer Perspektive
besonders mitdenken müssen wenn wir hier
in Kontakt mit diesen Ländern treten
weil hier kann man gemeinsame
Lösungsvorschläge erarbeiten und das
kann auch vertrauensbildend sein schauen
wir in den Osten für mich ist die
Ordnungsmacht Russland eindeutig im
Abstieg sonst wäre diese Eskalation um
ber Karabach in dieser Form sicher nicht
möglich gewesen und wir haben hier diese
fünf stanstaaten
Usbekistan Tadschikistan und dergleichen
die hier völlig neue frische Luft
plötzlich bekommen und Z sich zwischen
China und Europa positionieren können
und das ist auch eine Chance für Europa
dahinzuschauen und hinzugehen ich habe
schon erwähnt dieses Osteuropa das in
die EU und in der NATO dringt und
Russland eine Politik hat die eine
existenzielle ja von Europa bedeutet es
gibt hier strategische Vordenker in
Russland die sagen wir müssen uns vom
Westen abschotten weil nur so können wir
weiter bestehen wenn man Angst hat vor
Demokratie und Angst hat vor
Menschenrechten und Auswirkungen von
farbenrevolutionen auf das eigene Land
dann ist es wirklich so und das könnte
sein dass Krieg für den Präsidenten
Putin mittlerweile wirklich
unverzichtbar geworden ist um an der
Macht zu bleiben und Russland ist nicht
zu unterschätzen in seiner destruktiven
Außenpolitik wie ich das bezeichne und
wir sehen das vielerorts und das sehen
wir sogar V unserer Haustür in Bosnien
und im Kosovo darf man nicht
unterschätzen muss man dagegen halten
die russischen Waffen sind relativ
beschränkt deswegen ist es für mich auch
nur eine halbe Supermacht wenn man nicht
wirklich gestalten kann zwar weltweit
wirken aber nicht
gestalten wir wissen nicht wie es in der
Ukraine weitergeht derzeit deutet nichts
auf ein rasches Kriegsende hin auch
nicht auf Verhandlungen und auch nicht
auf große Veränderungen auf dem
gefechtsfelt heißt wieder
weitermachen was erwartet uns
daher wir werden diese asymmetrisch
multipolare Welt
weiterhen die Personen werden vielleicht
wechseln aber insgesamt wir diese
Konstellation die sehr viel Unsicherheit
und Instabilität bringt nicht verändert
werden wir haben in Europa einen neuen
eisernen Zahn Eisernen Vorhang wir haben
hier den Krieg in der Ukraine wir haben
eine unglaubliche Belastungsprobe für
die Europäische Union für den
Zusammenhalt es ist wichtig für die
transatlantische Partnerschaft
strategische Autonomie und wir müssen un
schon darauf einstellen dass
Migrationsdruck auf Dauer weiter
bestehen wird einfach aufgrund dieser
Instabilitäten in unserer Umgebung und
des
Bevölkerungszuwachses was heißt das ich
darf für den Herrn Scholz in mit seiner
Zeitenwende noch zitieren
was braucht man jetzt in
Europa für mich vollkommen klar es muss
eine abschreckungsfähigkeit gegenüber
Russland aufgebaut werden heißt nicht
dass man alle Bande abbricht und dass
man nicht versucht politisch ins
Geschäft zu kommen überhaupt keine Frage
aber wir müssen hier einfach Potenziale
in Europa haben Handlungsfähigkeit im
männerraum und eine vernünftige
Arbeitsteilung zwischen EU und NATO und
gerade angesichts der anstehenden Wahlen
eine solide
Sicherheitspartnerschaft zwischen EU und
und USA damit stürmische Zeiten denen
wir gegen sehen wir wissen noch nicht
wie sich Europa in diesem globalen
Konzert positionieren kann ich hoffe
doch dass es auf der Treppe ziemlich
weit oben
steht es gibt versuche hier in Europa
Mauern zu bauen wir wissen aber aus
vielen Erfahrungen es ist besser in
stürmischen Zeiten Segel zu setzen das
heißt nicht nur auf den eigenen
Kontinent zurückziehen sondern schon
immer darüber hinausdenken und darüber
hinausschauen in diesem Sinne wir hab
eine entscheidende Dekade FS die EU kann
nur geeim bestehen sie muss europäischen
Interessen Folgen nicht nur westlichen
europäischen Interessen
sondern europa braucht auch Partner und
wir gehen in eine Globalisierung 20
hinein wo sich die Welt neu aufstellt
neu formiert wie ich eingangs gesagt
habe und hier gilt es entsprechende
Partner zu finden wir brauchen nur die
Resi fragen und dann wissen wir schon
wie es weitergehen soll
in diesem Sinne ich habe eingangs gesagt
ich will ihen keinesfalls Angst machen
weil Angst ist kein guter Ratgeber und
außerdem mit Zuversicht oder betreuten
trinken ist ja alles möglich ist viel
viel mehr möglich schauen wir
optimistisch in die Zukunft V allem auch
deswegen weil wir nie weißen wie es
wirklich
weitergeht in diesem Sinne herzlichen
Dank
[Musik]
[Applaus]
od du mein Österreich so haben wir mit
dem goldenen Herzen Österreichs jetzt
aus dem kleinen Österreich in die Welt
hinausgeblickt mit akademischer
Perspektive und nun mehr schauen wir von
der Supermacht
ins Zentrum oder in das Zentrum unserer
Betrachtungen und ich darf nun general
Steven bchem ersuchen die
transatlantische Perspektive
darzustellen general
[Applaus]
fl
general
professorowit
leaders thank you for theortity with
youday
priv
transatp
a are challenging times so the them of
this year conrption day is fting rings
of Fire Europe
challenges however out challenges come
opporti from transatlanticpective the
United
statureure
russes war
ukraen great thre Europe
globally transatlantic security is based
on a strong enduring
Relation like one between our two
countries in 2019 the United States
austri began a strategic dial in
ureitate toarn from each
other as we all know from personal
experience productive Race relationships
don't Happ
overnight they are over time on
foundation of Mut
Trust war
marocus reconstruction recovery
Trans
tiationity those ti to ever before
United States
continue
EUFOR
SOV demra
Val
takeion
2014ority while theent wasl it awaken
urge to Inv in collec
defpite
russ'sowing its territorial
ambitions all still underinvested in
Security
unfortunately took Russ second invion of
ukra in febru
20 AAK
all unjusied unpred and illegal invasion
of Ukraine painted a clear picture that
Russia will not stop if it believes it
can advance interest through
Force this is a
challenge however this
challeng UniFi EU unified
nated
around the
world this is where we find
opportunity our 50 over 50 countries
including Austria are working through
the UN EU and NATO to support
Ukraine as we approach the twoye
anniversary of Russia's fullale
Assault Austria has made significant
contributions to countering Russia's
Aggression it has taken in more than
80,000 displ
ukraini provided 150 million EUR in
humanitaran a reconstruction and
recovery
orsed EU sanctions against Russia and
signed a framework agreement for the
construction of three hospitals in
Ukraine when Putin decided to further
invade Ukraine he failed to estimate the
internationalemnation straticcalculation
drove Sweden Finland to
natoession add of fin doubled the NATO
Russia border
compcatedations while the Alliance must
posture to credibly defend a longer
border NATO has never been stronger and
more unified in its commitment to
defending inch of Allied
territory this issolut an
opportunity Ming for we Main
Momentum
we greatly appreciate Austria's
steadfast support to NATO we know it
stems from a strong commitment dedicated
resolve Austria actively contributes to
the partnership for peace framework and
has for almost 30
years there longstanding major
contributor to natoleded Kosovo forces
for 25
years and they deployed service
membersghanistan as part of
international security assistance force
and its successor resolute Support
Mission
for all this I than
you likewi we appreate austri leadership
of the European Union
operationa since
2009 whichn austri praise from NATO m
States as well the people trust in
Bosnia
herzegov now tak a global view for
acnected the world is to
conflict in Europe extends far beyond
the geographic boundaries and affects
life on a global
scale according to the United Nations
Sustainable Development Group the war in
Ukraine has aggregated as aggravated a
global cost of living crisis and
comprises compromises lives liveloods
and ASP for
world more chenging he
diitytyending to
l mosted are the developing Anding
economies on energy Front Russia used
energy as a foreign policy tool as the
dominant
suppas
decadad Moscow cut estimated 80% of gas
previously delivered to
Europe however this dire challenge was
turned into opportunity when European
countries rallied and replaced large
portions of imported Gas with record
amounts of wind and solar energy the
kemlin ongoing weaponization of Pipeline
Gas promoted european capitals to reduce
Gas dependency on Russia once and for
all it's no secret conflict wars lead to
force displacement and
migration at the of
108.4 million people were displaced
worldwide this number reached the 100
million mark the highest number ever
record in the first half of 2022 due to
Russia's invasion of
Ra as this mon accing to United Nation
Commission
Morera for country war ukra lplacement
of Europe CZ World
War with women and children accounting
for most of the
refugees trly this is unpreded in
history
furthermore russuss
US
e
f cy
atts
disces Europe
alln
challengeesortityed commitment the
ofes
20edatch diom NW other countries and the
Europe Commission to create a dedicated
space for governments to work together
by Shing practices we can releve strain
on
nations we can deliver better solutions
for displaced people and the communi
that welcome them and we can improve
legal pathways and address obstacles
shared by many
nations when it comes to meeting the
challenges that Russ war agated for all
US the United States and Europe can do
much more together than on our
own the sense of solidarity and momentum
are crucial to our success going forward
simply stated Russia remains the core
Security challenge in the euroatlantic
region this is why enabling Raine to
defend its territory now is one of the
best ways to disuade Russia from future
Aggression
if Ukraine is unable to defend itself
successfully from Putin
Ono Russia will continue to be a threat
to the United States Europe and the
rulesbased international order that we
work so hard to establ in the decade
since World
War today Ukraine is the countryly
attacked by Russian Armed
Forces however
the repu of Moldova Georgia and other
countries in the south cauusue to face
Stratic intimidation
Russia these direct threats to their
sovty and territorial integrity increase
regional
instability ultimately Russia seeks to
outlast the West by manipulating energy
marketsuatuss
for for than was the war began
202 Russ Air naval and nuclear forces
remain relatively
unaffected if Russia is ready for a long
war in Ukraine we must taketion to PR
their attemps at fracturing European
unity under
us
tostain the war in Ukraine Putin is
miling his Society ramping up his Def
industrial
base all and partners must take AC
maintain
positionant
russityri
throughent Nation must continue toort
Ukraine as Russia mobiles for a long war
we must finds to accelerate
reconstitution efforts while challenging
russia'sility to
reconstitute establishing a defense
industrial base that can support a wars
consumption rate takes
years however policy
ches to enable us Def
toateuction
ourate more
ch add us europeaboration on we
systsab instead P for solutions to
become interoper
later in Ono commitment to peace and
stability Austria has taken strategic
steps toort the collec Def of
Europe 2 Nation
a
B
Herz
OP
auctep Oper promes Def cooperation and
supports Institution building in the
western
bans Austria has pushed for European
integration of these nations and
stressed the need toue Session talks
even while isocus on
was pleasure to a secretary
general and his staff they visited the
US European headquarters this past
November by and large the meeting was
another important step toward
strengthening our strategic relationship
with your country and and laid the
groundw for future
militaryoperation as I said then we look
forward to furthering our mutual
commitment to a shared vision of Europe
secity
by renewing the Austrian US
communication information security
memorandum of agreement this past
July it will add another 15
years we will of deepening our
Relation and commitment to keeping
Information safe in our connected
world now let me also highlight the
state partnership program relationship
between the Vermont National Guard and
Austria this vital
program brings together our military
forces to work side by side and to learn
from each other in fact a variety of
state partnership program activities
obviously were happening
recently how many of you had the chance
last night to actually listen to the
Vermont National Guard Band play at the
ball I would say last night and into
this morning
and
was finally
home from deoed together in Kosovo in
2021 as part of natosovo force Austrian
and Vermont National Guard Service
members went on to conduct multilateral
mountaining Warfare
Training North Macedonia toove
theardation storage
disposal Rang Training PRR Austrian Arm
forces infant Brigade to increase
interoperability and standard operating
procedures given Vermont economic and
agricultural Enterprise acutely mirror
those in Austria this partnership also
enhan economic growth opportunities for
Vermont and Austria through a whole of
society
approach several large businesses with
close ties to Austria already exist in
Vermont
now the deeper austri Vermont
partnership built upon the European
atltic security collective deterrents
and shared values will greatly enhance
the readiness
interopability of both our
militaries and over the coming years the
intent is to mutually improve in areas
of cyber Defense peace keepeping
operations again military mountainering
and humanitar disaster relief
in fact this is the collec benefit of
the state partnership program it's not
oneided we learn from you as much you
may learn from us
shedled so let me take just a second to
thank you one to the Austrian leaders
certainly to general dan h the chief of
the National Guard Bure and
most Commer of Vermont national for Supp
and personal leership in statenership
[Applaus]
prram but in all this opportunity let
not forg the
challeng Russia will continue to be
acute
Threat russiaose war Ukraine F
back and chose to defend its people and
sovereignty the world including our
countries also chose to come together
and stand with
Ukraine let remember Ukrainians are not
the only ones defending their country
they are defending they not only
defending their country they are
defending our shared
values
weure
aocra countri like the people Rep
China
Iran nor
koreatin all for help
UK
we AG R WE theeng
and together with our stronging Relation
we will help
maort while none of us conflict Russ it
will takelec strength to show mow will
achevetic objec with
force countri can invade peaceful neors
neorsr
for bas global security architecture
created at the San Francisco conference
in
1945 this gave birth to the UN Charter
and the rulesbased international order
that has KEP generations free from war
and
conflict as aent UN Security Council
Russia was usted with maintaining that
order instead it has Chos
place e the US secret of def a out
warob in 2
centyosper Sid
Atlan
neveress s Atlantic weareitment
ure safy and sec of our C and preserve
our bers and
life
R sovy
matters
freedom
matters through two world wars and the
Cold War the United States learned that
our security requires defending not only
the US homeland but the larger
transatlantic community which is why the
word stronger together means so much
more than just the US Europe
Comm United States does not
standone Austria does not stand alone in
fact no country can face the challenges
of today's increasly compx Security
environment
alone together both of our count stand
resolutely with European allies and
partn in a shared commitment to
euroatlantic Unity democratic values and
territorial
integrity yes the challenges
challesort United States
and together than
[Applaus]
you
[Musik]
[Applaus]
danke general bchem für ihre netten
Worte über die Beiträge Österreichs zur
kollektiven Sicherheit und der
degethofmsch hat nun mehr übergeleitet
zu einem
marineekapitän zu Lars Schümann
stellvertretender kabinetsdirektor des
EU military komites und der wird uns nun
die EU-Perspektive
erleitern ja Frau Ministerin Herr
general ganz herzlichen Dank
für die netten einführenden
Worte in der Tat
werde ich aus der euperspektive
berichten möchte aber vorausschicken
dass das meine persönlichen Anmerkungen
sind und meine persönlichen Ansichten um
das sehr deutlich zu machen ich danke
für die Einladung eine große Ehre für
mich ich soll sie selbstverständlich
herzlich grüßen auch ich persönlich von
Herrn general Brieger und wie sie gehört
haben bin ich ja in seinem Stab in
seinem Kabinett der stellvertretende
kabinettsdirektor und unterstütze ihn
hier mit vielen anderen Leuten
sehr regelmäßig und mit viel Engagement
da werde ich gleich auch noch mal ganz
kurz etwas zu sagen hinter mir auf dem
Bild sehen sie meinen Ring of Fire eine
Achterbahn die man auch im Internet
findet wenn man googelt und ich fand das
durchaus ein ganz angemessenes Bild denn
das was wir nicht nur in Brüssel sondern
sicherlich in vielen europäischen
Hauptstädten und sicherlich auch in
Washington sehen ist durchaus manchmal
eine sicherheitspolitische
Achterbahnfahrt wo man morgen nicht
genau weiß wo man stehen wird und was
wieder auf uns
zukommt ich werde Ihnen kurzen Überblick
geben über das was in Brüssel so läuft
werde sicherlich nicht in die Tiefe
gehen können bin Herrn generald
Feichtinger sehr dankbar dass er schon
sehr viel aus dem Ring of Fire
vorbereitet hat und werde dort gleich
nur kurz kürzer drauf eingehen können
dadurch das ist das Kabinett was ich
eben angespr habe nur um Ihnen auch hier
einmal einen kurzen Eindruck zu geben
der General Brieger hat hier fast 30
Leute um sich herin versammelt in seinem
Kabinett die ihn unterstützen um
wirklich auch die militärische
Perspektive in der Europäischen Union
und in Brüssel nach vorne zu bringen
denn die EU muss
lernen sie muss auch lernen die
instruments of power zu benutzen das ist
etwas was der EU nicht in der DNA liegt
das muss man ganz klar sagen ähm vor 25
Jahren ganz grob ging es los ähm aber
erst jetzt so langsam wird klar
wo wir denn eigentlich
auch unsere Hebel ansetzen
müssen ich möchte mit Ihnen heute ganz
kurz in den nächsten 15 bis 20 Minuten
einmal ganz kurz durch die
sicherheitspolitische Struktur der EU
gehen weil das glaube ich auch ganz
wichtig ist sich noch einmal zu
vergegenwärtigen was das eigentlich für
ein interessantes Konstrukt ist und wer
hier so alles eine Rolle spielt und
mitspricht
dann auf die Herausforderungen vor denen
wir stehen eingehen Herausforderungen
die auch immer Chancen beinhalten das
haben wir gehört
und dann
möchte ich Ihnen kurz darlegen wie denn
die EU auch den Versuch
von Antworten äh versucht zu
geben
das also ist äh in ganz grober Übersicht
äh die äh Struktur der EU überwiegend in
Brüssel nicht alles in Brüssel
disloziert es ist wichtig zu verstehen
dass wir in der EU einen supranationalen
Körper haben mit der Kommission die im
Grunde eine Art Regierung für Europa ist
und schon sehr
weitreichende Kompetenzen auch hat ähm
und auf der anderen Seite haben wir den
Rat wo die Mitgliedstaaten vertreten
sind und dann gibt es natürlich noch das
EU-Parlament dass wir im juniah neu
wählen werden und dann wird sich
sicherlich auch vieles bewegen wieder in
Brüssel also wir haben einen
interguvernmentalen Anteil und einen
supranationalen Anteil und die
sicherheits- und Verteidigungspolitik
ist klassischerweise im
interguvernmentalen Anteil verortet also
dort wo die Mitgliedstaaten das Sagen
haben die Herausforderung ist allerdings
dass ich der Begriff der der
Sicherheitspolitik insbesondere in den
letzten sagen wir mal zwei Jahrzehnten
äh wirklich verändert hat und viele
Bereiche der Politik die wir früher
nicht klassisch der Sicherheitspolitik
zugeordnet haben sich dort aber auch
mittlerweile mehr und mehr verorden
lassen äh wenn wir an die
Verteidigungsindustrie denken aber auch
wenn wir insgesamt an die
Wirtschaftspolitik denken die ä ja auch
mehr und mehr instrumentalisiert wird
ähm auch für ähm machtpolitische Fragen
und insofern muss man diese beiden Dinge
zusammenend denken und das macht es in
der EU durchaus manchmal auch
ähm schwieriger äh dort äh zu äh zu zu
sachgerechten umfassenden Entscheidungen
zu kommen und natürlich ist es eine
besondere Herausforderung in sich auch
im Rat immer die Einstimmigkeit der 27
Mitgliedstaaten äh zu erreichen denn das
ist ein
Grundprinzip da gehen wir mal drüber
hinweg der krisenbogen den hat der
General dr Feichtinger wie ich finde
ausgezeichnet beschrieben
ich habe eine etwas andere Perspektive
hier
genommen wir sehen also wirklich einen
Bogen um uns herum ich gehe nicht in die
Einzelheiten ein ich möchte nur schon
mal darauf hinweisen dass die EU
drei Schwerpunkte im Moment vordringlich
bearbeitet das ist natürlich die Frage
wie machen wir in Afrika weiter die
Herausforderungen dort sind schon
herausgearbeitet worden wie schaffen wir
es das Vertrauen wieder herzustellen und
dort als Partner wahrgenommen zu werden
und
eine ein Lösungsansatz ist es sicherlich
dass wir nicht nur als Partner
wahrgenommen werden sondern auch die
afrikanischen Staaten selbstverständlich
als Partner wahrnehmen und ihnen auf
Augenhöhe begegnen das muss sicherlich
äh noch stärker der Fall sein als es
bisher
der Fall ist der zweite wesentliche
Handlungsort
ist natürlich die Ukraine es ist durch
general bcham eben sehr gut
herausgearbeitet worden
was in der Ukraine für uns als Europäer
auf dem Spiel steht und das ist etwas
was nach meinem Eindruck
teilweise in der Politik ganz sicherlich
in der Bevölkerung
nicht überall wirklich verstanden wurde
welche Rolle
unsere Unterstützung der Ukraine im
Krieg gegen die gegen Russland
wirklich
spielt
und man muss da natürlich immer im
Hinterkopf behalten
dass es nicht nur um die Ukraine alleine
geht sondern um die russische Rolle
gegenüber Europa aber auch darüber
hinaus und äh russisches
hegemonialverhalten
der dritte krisenort den wir im Moment
sehr intensiv im Auge haben ist das Rote
Meer
eine wirtschaftlich
ein ein Ort von wirtschaftlich größter
Bedeutung für Europa der Ort durch den
fast alles was wir bei uns im Haushalt
so finden
durchläuft auf dem Weg nach Europa und
insofern ist das Offenhalten dieser
Seewege und das sage ich natürlich als
Marineoffizier
mit besonderem nach Druck von größter
Bedeutung und im Moment wird in Brüssel
wirklich mit Hochdruck gearbeitet um
dort auch als Europäische Union zu
zeigen dass wir unsere Interessen dort
bereit sind zu verteidigen und es sind
nicht nur unsere Interessen sondernn es
ist natürlich auch geltendes Recht und
die rechtsbasierte Weltordnung für die
wir immer wieder und überall eintreten
wollen es gibt eine andere Art und Weise
auf den krisenbogen zu gucken der ist
etwas mehr 360° lastig
ähm hier sehen wir genau wie von General
dr Feichtinger auch schon angesprochen
eben auch dass die Arktis natürlich
mittlerweile eine Rolle spielt dass wir
auch in die Karibik und nach Südamerika
gucken müssen wir müssen nicht als
äh als als Bedrohung selbstverständlich
aber als äh als Bestandteil unserer
Partnerschaft natürlich nach Nordamerika
gucken ähm und müssen dort ä für die
Nordamerikaner auch äh ein ein ein
wertvoller Partner sein damit die
transatlantische Partnerschaft ähm auch
langfristig Bestand hat denn das ist
natürlich zweifellos äh dass die
transatlantische Bindung für uns als
Europäer von größter Bedeutung ist und
darüber hinaus äh dann weiter um uns
herum ich habe China vorhin nicht
erwähnt aber das ist natürlich der
langfristige Elefant im Raum ähm inwi
weit ähm sich hier äh territoriale
Expansionspläne ähm manifestieren in
Zukunft in wie weit China in auch
weiterhin in Zukunft auf dem
afrikanischen Kontinent äh vertreten ist
und möglicherweise zukünftig auch noch
stärker militärisch was ja bisher nicht
der Fall ist und
ähm wie denn ähm auch ansonsten ähm die
Wert und Weltordnung wie wir sie kennen
durch China möglicherweise in Zukunft
mehr geprägt wird als das bisher der
Fall ist und das ist etwas was natürlich
unser allerleben und insbesondere das
der
nachfolgeneration sehr stark ähm
beeinträchtigen und beeinflussen wird
nicht zuletzt möchte ich auch noch
erwähnen dass wir natürlich ähm einzelne
Region nicht separat voneinander
betrachten können und sollten die dieser
ganze krisenbogen wenn man ihn sich
genau anguckt hat sehr viele
Verbindungen untereinander und diese
Dinge muss man strategisch mit
miteinander verbunden sehen um auch
einen strategischen Ansatz zu finden wie
man dieses dann
ähm
selber strategisch bearbeiten
kann was hat die äh die EU gemacht
äh ich habe ihn hier aufgelegt den
strategischen Kompass äh das letzte
größere strategische Dokument der EU die
versucht der versucht hat viele
Antworten zu finden möchte kurz
vorausschicken dass die EU eben wie ich
das eingangs gesagt habe erst seit
ungefähr 25 Jahren ein auch äh
sicherheitspolitisches Instrument ist
und damit natürlich noch relativ jung
ist wir haben unsere erste Lehre gezogen
aus dem Balkankrieg wir haben wenn man
so will die zweite Lehre gezogen ähm aus
der Besetzung der Krim durch Russland
und dann sind wir natürlich noch mal
wirklich aufgewacht ähm als es dann zum
heißen Krieg zwischen Russland und der
Ukraine im vorvergangenen Jahr kam und
in dieser Situation
hat die EU die ihren strategischen
Kompass erlassen
indem sie zum einen erstmalig auch mit
allen 27 abgestimmt eine
Bedrohungsanalyse vorgenommen hat also
um erst einmal ein gemeinsames
Verständnis endlich davon zu schaffen
wie sie die Welt um uns herum eigentlich
aus und
wie sind unsere strategischen ha
Herausforderungen was äh ein ein sehr
wichtiger Schritt ist um auch den Aspekt
der Solidarität in der EU stärker zu
fördern und ich denke das ist
schon sehr gut gelungen mit diesem
Dokument und dann war es zweitens
ein ein wichtiges Dokument um auch
wirklich konkrete Handlungsansätze zu
finden wie wir unseren
Herausforderungen begegnen können und
ich will ihn nur äh lass lass sich davon
nicht überfahren bitte
ein einen kurzen Eindruck geben das ist
aus über 80 Handlungsfeldern die wir in
in diesem Kompass bearbeitet haben
eine kleine Auswahl der wichtigsten
möchte nur darauf eingehen dass und ich
komme auf zwei Aspekte gleich noch mal
zurück zum einen wir ein starkes
militärisches auch kurzfristig
verfügbares militärisches Instrument mit
der sogenannten rapid deployment
capacity schaff wollen und wir sind da
auf einem sehr guten Weg ich möchte Sie
darauf hinweisen dass natürlich auch ein
zukünftiges morgiges Kriegsbild stark
auf Hybriden Bedrohungen basieren wird
dass wir es geschafft haben dort mit der
sogenannten Hybrid Toolbox unsere
Instrumente zum erkennen und bekämpfen
hybrider Bedrohungen gebündelt haben was
sehr wichtig ist auch im Sinne von Best
Practices und Austausch von Erfahrung
dass wir
erkannt haben welche Rolle die
sogenannten global common spielen also
die Räume die uns als Menschheit zur
Verfügung stehen frei zur Verfügung
stehen insbesondere der
Weltraum das Netz das
cybernetz und natürlich auch die hohe
See und dass wir bereit sind für die für
die Freiheit auch dieser und freie
Nutzung dieser Räume uns einzusetzen und
zuletzt und das ist auch sehr wichtig im
Bereich der des Investments dass wir
besser und gemeinsamer beschaffen wollen
und dazu werde ich gleich auch noch mal
was sagen weil das schon auch
revolutionär
ist bereits vor dem Kompass vor dem
strategischen Kompass hat die Marine
erkann Entschuldigung hat die EU
erkannt hat die EU erkannt ähm dass ähm
das wirklich Handlungsbedarf besteht und
es wurden daort schon die ersten
interessanten Schritte gemacht mit
sogenannten
verteidigungsinitiativen wo wir uns
besser abstimmen äh und wir stärker
schon äh ich sage es mal mit dem Wort
ähm ähm uns integrativ äh miteinander
auseinandersetzen und stärker ähm
zusammenarbeiten wir haben ein wir sind
einen wichtigen Schritt gegangen indem
wir in Brüssel ein zentrales
militärisches Führungsinstrument
geschafft haben
mit der sogenannten mit dem sogenannten
mpcc
der
military command capacity und das ist
wirklich ein ein ein wichtiger Schritt
gewesen dass wir führungsfähig werden
und was ganz wichtig ist
und das steht
immer bei uns sehr weit oben auf der
Priorit l die Zusammenarbeit mit der
NATO denn Sicherheit in Europa kann ohne
die NATO nicht gedacht werden und das
ist wirklich elementar und es gibt auch
viele Überschneidung und deswegen ist es
so wichtig dass wir dort auch keine
Doppelstrukturen schaffen und dass wir
uns eng miteinander austauschen da gibt
es Hürden das ist gar keine Frage aber
wir gehen wirklich hier Schritte die
bisher auch nicht denkbar gewesen
sind
und vieles wird unternommen und da
möchte ich jetzt einmal einen ganz
kurzen Blick auf ähm die Dinge werfen
die in der Kommission insbesondere
gemacht werden aber auch in der
europäischen verteidigungsagentur die
dort unterstützt und da sind
insbesondere zwei Aspekte in den Blick
genommen worden äh nachdem Russland der
russland-ukraine Krieg begonnen hat und
darum geht es geht um um zwei Dinge das
erste ist den Aufbau der
Verteidigungsindustrie in Europa wir
müssen wieder verteidigungsfähig werden
dazu brauchen wir Fähigkeiten und die EU
hat gemerkt dass sie dort
unterstützen muss und will und das macht
die Kommission und dort werden
Instrumente geschaffen sind Instrumente
geschaffen worden um die Industrie zu
unterstützen im Aufbau ihrer Kapazitäten
und das zweite ist und das ist wirklich
revolutionär dass die EU als Institution
die Mitgliedstaaten in der gemeinsamen
Beschaffung von militärischen
Fähigkeiten unterstützt undenkbar
gewesen vor wenigen Jahren ja und jetzt
passiert es und insofern muss man auch
wirklich feststellen wenn der EU der
Vorwurf gemacht wird dass sie zu langsam
ist was in Teilen sicherlich nicht
verkehrt ist wenn man das sagt wenn man
zurückguckt 25 Jahre was wir in diesen
25 Jahren geschafft haben wo wir heute
stehen und wir werden sicherlich schnell
weitermachen und wir sehen ja auch eine
Beschleunigung dieser Prozesse dann
ähm darf man doch sehr optimistisch sein
dass die EU in schneller Zeit ein
besserer Sicherheits Gestalter wird ganz
kurz die das militärische Instrument der
Sicherheits der der militärischen äh
Handlungsfähigkeit die EU EU readiness
äh
ich habe es nicht verstanden ich habe
den ja ja die die ADC ja lassen wirs mal
dabei deployment dieses Wort meine Güte
entschuldigen sie bitte deployment
capacity die wirklich in der Mitte steht
dessen was wir im Moment militärisch
planen und hier geht es darum dass wir
militärisch schnell eingreifen können
weil uns immer wieder aufgefallen ist
dass wir unsere Kräfte nicht schnell
genug dahin bekommen
wo wir sie brauchen und das ganze ist
natürlich nicht nur eine Frage der
Verfügbarkeit von Fähigkeiten da spielt
viel mehr eine Rolle da spielt eine
Rolle welche command and control
Systematik können wir dafür benutzen wie
sieht der
entscheidungsfindungsmechanis
entscheidungsfindungsmechanismus
dahinter aus ähm wie äh beüben wir diese
Kräfte äh wie halten wir Sie in
Bereitschaft wie wird das finanziert ähm
und das sind alles Dinge die wir jetzt
mitdenken und die dann zu einem großen
Ganzen deswegen habe ich das Architektur
genannt ja
zusammenbinden um sie dann verfügbar zu
haben und das ist ein wesentlicher
Schritt den wir bis Anfang nächsten
Jahres dann auch äh zum äh zum zur
vollen Einsatzbereitschaft bringen
wollen und wir sind auf dem guten Weg
und ich bin da sehr optimistisch dass
wir in Zukunft ein Instrument an der
Hand haben um schnellhandlungsfähig zu
werden zu guter Letzt alles
gut vermutlich noch nicht ich habe ihnen
sehr viel über Fähigkeiten und
fähigkeitsentwicklung erzählt am Ende
hängt sehr vieles davon ab sind wir
politisch
willig uns dort in der EU einzubringen
und haben wir die richtigen
entscheidungsfindungsmechanismen und da
kann man über viele Dinge noch
nachdenken wie wir die
Entscheidungsfindung beschleunigen
können und wie
wir besser
die unsere Fähigkeiten ans Ziel bringen
also insofern ist es noch ein Weg zu zu
gehen ich denke wir müssen über stärkere
auch Integration nachdenken im
militärischen Bereich und wenn wir
diesen Weg gehen dann bin ich sehr
optimistisch dass wir für die für die
nächsten Jahre eine handlungsfähige EU
sehen herzlichen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Dank
[Applaus]
[Musik]
der Rudolf Striedinger Marsch war die
perfekte Überleitung zum
abschlussreferat Herr general Rudolf
stredinger die österreichische
Perspektive
bitte sehte Frau Bundesministerin sehrte
Präsident meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren ich hoffe der Marsch hat Ihnen
gefallen ich der Jahre als
Militärkommandant wo ich den 20 Mal
gehört habe jedes Mal wenn ich zum Reden
gekommen bin bei einer Angelobung oder
sonst irgendwo und mir gefällt da
wirklich gut und ich habe auch die
Bundesministerin zugesehen beinahe so
wie gestern am Ball nicht ganz aber
doch da herzlichen Dank an die gadeem
Musik dafür ihr könnt es mittlerweile
wirklich
gut ich möchte mich auch bedanken
zunächst einmal dafür dass ich heute
wieder hier stehen und sprechen darf das
ist ja keine
Selbstverständlichkeit ich bedanke mich
aber auch bei meinen Vorrednern für den
Bogen den Sie gespannt haben weil ich
dann auf diese Aspekte ja überhaupt
nicht mehr eingehen brauch
ich möchte aber das ergänzen durch drei
persönliche Eindrücke die ich im
Zusammenhang mit dem was wir jetzt
gerade gehört haben erfahren habe und
das auch zeitlich rein das erste war das
vor drei vor drei Monaten also im
Oktober des Vorjahres stattgefundene EU
generalstabcheftreffen in Spanien wo wir
viel über die Ukraine gesprochen haben
und V allem über die Auswirkung der
Ukraine auf die Europäische Union und
die Streitkräfte der Europäischen Union
und da die
Stimmungslage nicht gut nicht gut und
zwar deswegen weil einigen Ländern die
Mittel ausgehen Munition Waffen und weil
vor allem die
generalopchefs noch nicht erkennen
konnten weil es eben noch nicht war dass
offensichtlich die Notwendigkeit die
Industrie dazu zu motivieren dafür zu
sorgen dass die Bestände wieder
aufgefüllt werden eben noch nicht in die
Gänge gekommen
ist mein zweiter Eindruck war
vorgestern ich war beim NATO
generalstscheft treffen als eine der
partnernationen
und wir haben danach die Partner mit dem
chair dem Admiral Rob Bauer ein
gemeinsames Mittagessen gehabt und der
hat dann berichtet aus dem NATO Meeting
wir war natürlich einen Teil dabei aber
natürlich nicht das ganze die ganze
Session und
dort war das Bild ganz
anders die Stimmungslage war positiv
überraschend positiv
und dann hat er es auch begründet warum
das so ist und er hat also gesagt allein
die
Allianz hat rund 50% der
weltwirtschaftskraft und das ist das ist
nicht
wenig und die beste Voraussetzung dafür
im Bedarfsfall auch dazu dafür zu sorgen
dass auch militärische Kräfte
entsprechend ausgerüstet ausgest erden
können um denen den Herausforderungen zu
entsprechen und wenn man jetzt dann noch
die Partner die dort am Tisch dabei
waren dazu rechnet wobei ich jetzt nicht
Österreich meine ich meine jetzt auch
nicht die Schweiz und ich meine auch
nicht Irland aber ich meine z.B
Australien und Neuseeland oder Japan
oder
Südkorea dann ergibt das schon ein
ordentliches Volumen und es war sehr
interessant
zu spüren dass die Stimmungslage einfach
sich in die richtige Richtung gewandelt
hat möglicherweise auch unter dem Aspekt
dass die Europäische Union wie
dargestellt in die Gänge kommt was
die das Anlaufen von
Kriegs produzierenden Waffen und
Munition produzierenden Rüstungsgütern
betrifft und der letzte Eindruck war in
Wirklichkeit der gestrige und in den
heutigen Morgen reichende Tag den wir
gestern am Vormittag mit unseren
Partnern
insbesondere den Amerikanern aber auch
der NATO muss man dazu sagen sehr offen
bestritten haben und eines ist klar
geworden und das ist auch heute sehr
schön dargestellt
worden Partnerschaft ist ein
gegenseitiger Vorgang und wenn wir
unsere Partnerschaft mit der National
Mond haben dann lernen wir gegenseitig
voneinand und das ist das was so im
Zentrum steht
und
das ist etwas wo wir durchaus mit einem
gewissen Bewusstsein und auf Augenhöhe
agieren und alle Kooperationen die ich
jetzt damit umfasse und meine sind die
Grundvoraussetzung dafür dass wir
überhaupt sinnvoll
äh Verteidigung Landesverteidigung und
Schutz unsere bevölk betreiben können
und gemessen an dem was wir tun und das
möchte ich jetzt ja in ein paar Minuten
kurz zusammenfassen sind wir unter dem
Gesichtspunkten die ich jetzt
dargestellt habe und die dargestellt
worden sind aus meiner Sicht absolut auf
dem richtigen
Weg ich bin vor einem Jahr hier
gestanden und habe ihnen gesagt was wir
vorhaben im vorigen Jahr im Jahr
2023 und habe und das ist heute ja schon
kurz Anges ochen dargestellt wie dieser
Aufbauplan des österreichischen
bundeshahres 2032 plus grob ausschaut
mit diesen drei Kategorien wobei eines
der ganz wesentlichen Elemente dieser
Bezeichnung das Plus hinten dran ist es
endet nicht 2032 sondern das ist jetzt
ein Rahmen der auch finanziell gesichert
ist durch das von der Frau
Bundesministerin dargestellte
landesverteidigungsfinanzierungsgesetz
aber es ist klar und wir gehen ja nicht
davon aus dass die Welt friedlicher und
ruhiger wird in der nächsten Zeit dass
das ein Zwischenschritt und nur ein
Zwischenschritt auf einer
Weiterentwicklung des Bundesheeres sein
kann meine Schwergewichte des vorigen
Jahres waren das zusätzlich zugewiesene
Geld richtig ausgeben und zwar richtig
und
ausgeben zweiter Punkt die die Planungen
für das bundesjahr
2032 im Wesentlichen
abschließen und dritter Punkt dafür
sorgen dass sich die Personallage des
Bundesheeres richtig entwickelt das war
damals der dritte Punkt und das war
tatsächlich eine Reihenfolge eine
prioritätenreihenfolge jetzt nach diesem
Jahr kann ich Ihnen sagen das Ziel
Nummer ein haben wir absolut erreicht
mit 100 02% ungefähr haben wir das
landesverteidigungsbudget ausgegeben es
ist nichts übrig geblieben ganz im
Gegenteil und wir haben es vor allem
richtig ausgegeben weil wir viele Dinge
ins Laufen gebracht haben vertraglich
fixiert haben auch in die Tiefe der Zeit
was dem Finanzministerium manchmal
Kopfzerbrechen macht oder zumindest
schweißberlen auf die Stirne treibt weil
wir eine Vorbelastung in die Zukunft
erzeugen aber es geht bei Rüstung nicht
anders das wissen wir
alle der zweite Punkt die Planungen wie
soll das Bundesheer 2032
ausschauen
abschließen das ist erledigt im
Wesentlichen sind die Dokumente fertig
geschrieben wir haben jetzt eine klare
Vorstellung wie das ausschauen soll und
werden die Umsetzung einleiten wir
werden dazu unsere Bundesministerin noch
entsprechend einweisen und ersuchen auch
den Grundauftrag dafür zu
erteilen ich lebe wirklich einen sehr
angenehmen Leben diesbezüglich weil ich
bekomme eine klare allgemeine Vorgabe in
Wirklichkeit z.B Aufbauplan umsetzen
mehr ist es nicht und innerhalb dieses
Rahmens kann ich mich mit meinen Planern
mit meinen rüstern mit allen meinen
Leuten entsprechend bewegen und wir
können das Ziel sehr konzentriert
verfolgen zum Personal sage ich jetzt
noch nichts da komme ich am
Schluss wir haben und das ist
signifikant und wenn ich mit anderen
generalstschef spreche und Geld ist ja
wie wir wissen immer nur ein bisschen
auch relativ eine
budgentwicklung die sonst kaum wo in
dieser Dimension stattfindet wir haben
vom Jahr 2022 allein auf das heuge Jahr
also innerhalb von zi Jahren eine
budgetsteigerung von über
50% und wenn ich jetzt schaue wie viel
davon vorrangig oder ausschließlich für
Investitionen vorgesehen ist dann ist es
eine mehrfache
Steigerung und ich kann Ihnen sagen wir
brauchen das Geld ich war etwas
überrascht dass wir so rasch in die
Gänge kommen bin aber drauf gekommen
dass wir vor nicht geschlafen haben
sondern offensichtlich die Dinge die wir
hätten eh dringend machen müssen
vorbereitet gehabt haben und daher
relativ rasch die
entsprechenden Arbeiten umsetzen
konnten der wesentliche Kern des
landesverteidigungs
finanzierungsgesetzes ist ein
stufenweises Anwachsen des Budgets bis
2028 und dann eine wertgesicherte
weitere Entwicklung auf der Basis von
1,5%
BIP wir haben und das ist unserer
politischen Führung zu verdanken für das
heurie Jahr im Jahr 2024 dieses Ziel
erreicht es ist ein
außergewöhnliches dass ein
Verteidigungsbudget im
Rahmen im Finanzrahmen der vier Jahre im
nächsten Jahr steigt kann also das ist
etwas was ich überhaupt noch nicht
erlebt habe dass da etwas mehr wird in
der Regel wurde es zumindest in den
letzten 15 Jahren immer weniger aber
nachdem Teuerung und andere BIP
Berechnungen dazu geführt haben sind wir
tatsächlich über die 4 Milliarden
gekommen und das ist wirklich die
Grundvoraussetzung dafür dass wir
heuer diesen Aufbauplan auch tatsächlich
fortsetzen können und meine vorgab
für meine Planer und
Rüster und die infrastrukturleute ist
heuer eine Spur anders als voriges Jahr
heuer habe ich Ihnen
vorgegeben machen wir möglichst viele
Projekte mit möglichst geringen
budgetansätzen gängig das heiß schauen
wir dass wir möglichst viel Verträge
schließen um sozusagen mit einer
Vielzahl von Vorhaben in die nächsten
Jahre zu
gehen es ist kein Geheimnis dass heute
Heu in Österreich gewählt wird meine
Aufgabe sehe ich darin die
Voraussetzungen zu schaffen dass dieser
Weg der jetzt eingeschlagen ist und der
äh eine zwingende Notwendigkeit ist für
die Sicherheit Österreichs auch
konsequent weiter fortgesetzt werden
kann und das kann man z.B auch mit so
einer Maßnahme
sicherstellen der Aufbauplan den kann
man auch ein bisschen anders verstehen
was die
Kategorisierung von
Waffensystemen etc betrifft und wenn man
sich das ein bisschen näher anschaut
dann stellt man fest dass die jetzt
zugesprochene Mittel in Wirklichkeit
allerhöchste Eisenbahn waren in manchen
Bereichen sogar de facto zu spät und ich
nenne jetzt diese vier
Kategorien die Kategorie 1 ist wir haben
ein altes Gerät das ist so alt dass muss
weggeben und kaufen was neues bestes
Beispiel von Aloe 3 auf a 169
Hubschrauber bestes Beispiel C130
c390 bestes Beispiel
ab212 Hubschrauber wird ersetzt durch
eine zweite blackhock Staffel diese
Dinge
dringend notwendig weil sonst hätten wir
das nicht also höchste Eisenbahn zweite
Kategorie wir haben etwas was schon in
die Jahre gekommen ist und wir machen
modernisieren es bestes Beispiel die
gesamte mechflotte also alle Kampfpanzer
kampfschützenpanzer auch die
Fliegerabwehr 3,5 cm fliegerabwehrkanone
Mistral etc das heißt das sind Systeme
wo wir sagen okay die die kann man noch
weiter brauchen und verwenden wir müssen
sie nur modernisieren auf einen neuen
Stand bringen dritte Kategorie wir
kaufen von gewissen Dinge einfach
mehr bestes
Beispiel
Pandur wir hatten ungefähr 70 80 ist
dann beschlossen W wir kaufen noch 100
dazu wir werden Heu einen Vertrag machen
über 220 zusätzlich und werden dann im
Endeffekt ein mal 400 pandure haben und
denkbar in der Vergangenheit das heißt
wir kommen hier deutlich weiter und das
ist etwas wo sich Zahlen in der
bestellungsliste verändern aber nicht
großarig zusätzlich eine Arbeit entsteht
und die vierte Kategorie ist wirklich
wichtig es sind neue
Fähigkeiten bestes Beispiel Drohnen und
zwar
unterschiedlichster
Kategorie weiteres Beispiel mittlere und
lang
weitreichende Fliegerabwehr also
bodengebundene Luft
Luftabwehr und da bin ich sehr glücklich
darüber dass die Bundesregierung den
Beschluss gefasst hat dass wir nicht nur
auf der mittleren Reichweite stehen
bleiben dieser Teil ist nämlich
finanziell abgegolten oder einberechnet
im Aufbauplan sondern darüber hinaus
über die Long Range air
deffense gehen können mit einer
zusätzlichen zusätzlichen Finanzierung
weil das geht sich in dem Rahmen nicht
aus und damit befinden wir uns mit
unseren Nachbarn auf einer Ebene und das
ist entscheidend gerade im Luftbereich
ist das entscheidend weil da können wir
uns dieses Loch das wir sonst
produzieren würden einfach nicht mehr
leisten und daher gibt es für mich für
das heue jah wieder drei Schwergewichte
das eine ist wir starten die
Umsetzung damit verbunden und damit ein
zweiter Punkt und das ist keine leichte
Aufgabe wir schauen dass wir koordiniert
Vorgehen in den unterschiedlichen wir
nennen es
Entwicklungslinien also wir brauchen
wenn wir ein Material kaufen das
Personal das es bedienen kann die
Infrastruktur dass man unterstellen kann
die Vorschriften dit man es bedienen
kann und so weiter und so fort diese
Dinge müssen Harmon laaufen eine
riesenkoordinierungsaufgabe der
wichtigste Bereich ist aber der
Personalbereich
eindeutig und zusammen mit der
sektionschefin und auch mit dem
milizbeauftragten bin ich da in
intensiven Gesprächen wie wir auch unter
dem Gesichtspunkt einer heranstehenden
Nationalratswahl uns als österreichches
Bundesheer und das Bundesministerium
aufstellen müssen um genau die Fragen
die entstehen wenn es um Personal des
präsenzstandes geht aber viel mehr noch
wenn es um die Frage des einsatzbereiten
mobil gemachten Bundesheeres geht um das
auf die richtigen Beine zu stellen und
klar zustellen genauso wie im
materiellenbereich was wir
brauchen und nachdem das sehr stark mit
politischen Entscheidungen verbunden
ist geht es mir darum dass wir
klarstellen wie die Lage ist und was aus
unserer Sicht erforderlich ist um dann
entsprechend zusammen eine richtige
Entscheidung zu treffen denn das gesamte
System Bundesheer funktioniert dann wenn
alle Komponenten entsprechend gegeben
sind
und wenn heute die rapid deployment
capacity so umfassend angesprochen wurde
so möchte ich schon darauf hinweisen
dass wir so wie die Frau
Bundesministerin gesagt hat alle unsere
Aufgaben die wir zugewiesen bekommen aus
unserer Sicht wirklich gut erfüllen auch
die in den
Auslandseinsätzen und die manchmal
geordnete Kritik wir sein jetzt nicht
mehr so stark bei KFOR dabei möchte ich
schon ein bisschen relativieren weit de
facto haben wir im Logistikbereich ein
bisschen etwas weggenommen damit wir es
bei der RDC wo wir zusammen mit den
deutschen nächstes Jahr quasi im ersten
ja der vollen Einsatzbereitschaft der
rapid deployment capacity tatsächlich
auch unseren Mann und unsere Frau
stellen müssen da gibt es keine
Alternative dazu weil ich leiste mir
diesen Bauchfleck nicht und daher und
ich gehe davon aus dass es auch sonst
keiner haben will da ist ein kleines
heruntergehen bei Kfer durchaus
verträglich und so wie alle anderen
generalstchfs festgestellt haben wir
müssen ins Tun kommen es ist genug
gesprochen worden Handeln ist jetzt
angesagt dafür daher tun wir es und ich
bin sehr froh drüber dass ich so viele
Verbündete heute hier sehe mit denen
zusammen wir dieses Tun auch erfolgreich
gestalten werden vielen
[Applaus]
Dank
herzlichen Dank lieber rude Herr general
ich darf ein paar zusammenfassende Worte
finden wir haben gehört Sicherheit ist
vernetzt die Welt der Sicherheit ist
multipolar geworden heißt umgekehrt auch
Unsicherheit entsteht dort wo
Zersplitterung herrscht die
Kriegsführung ist Hybrid geworden wir
bekommen gar nicht immer mit dass wir in
einem Krieg sind Kriege werden auch
nicht mehr Kriege genannt und das
Völkerrecht spielt eine geringe oder gar
keine Rolle wie ist die Perspektive für
morgen übermorgen die nächsten Jahre sie
ist a unklar aber B es ist nicht zu
erwarten dass wir in einen friedlichen
Zustand wie vor einigen Jahren
zurückkehren wir dürfen nicht darauf
hoffen dass es einfach von alleine
besser wird ein Cartoon von Heger dem
schrecklichen
zeigt wie er sich überlegt I do or I
don't und finally kommt er zu dem
Schluss okay we overrun Europe es wird
wohl nicht Heger sein der diesen
auszehlreim macht möglicherweise andere
die Frage ist sind wir dafür
bereit ich habe am Anfang die metaphor
des Herzen verwendet wenn wir diese auf
das österreichische Bundes her anwenden
dann kann man sagen na ja so vor 10
Jahren war das österreichische
Bundesheer auf der
Intensivstation es haben dann Minister
vor unserer jetzigen ich sage ein mal
die Minister toskcozil oder kunasek das
österreichische bundesher aus der
Intensivstation aufs Aufwachzimmer
gebracht und unter deiner jetzigen
Anleitung gehen wir in die
Rehabilitationsphase um in den nächsten
Jahren wieder Kampfkraft aufzubauen
aber für eine sportliche Meisterleistung
reicht es möglicherweise noch immer
nicht deshalb wurde auch betont an
diesem Aufbauplan 2032 ist vor allem
auch das Plus ganz besonders wichtig das
kann bedeuten dass hinten noch was folgt
aber vielleicht auch dass man bis
dorthin auch die Anstrengungen noch
zusätzlich erhöhen muss wenn man nicht
davon ausgehen kann dass wir alle diese
Zeit der Welt vielleicht auch haben und
das bringt mich auch zu der Kernfrage
die der generalstabchef zum Schluss
angesprochen hat die Personalfrage er
hat verklausuliert sich was gewunschen
es wurde heute gesagt die Plattform und
ihre Mitgliedsorganisationen haben in
der Vergangenheit die Dinge nicht
verklausuliert angesprochen sondern klar
und deutlich und sie haben am Ende des
Tages auch mit ihren Prognosen Recht
behalten daher sagen wir auch diesmal
klar und deutlich bei der Personalfrage
ist eine entscheidende Antwort offen
kehren wir zu den verpflichtenden
Übungen zurück oder tun wir das nicht
verlängern wir die werdienstzeit oder
tun wir es
nicht das ist eine Frage zu der die
Plattform aber auch alle
Mitgliedsverbände dieser Plattform eine
eindeutige Position haben wir treten
dafür ein dass 6 + 2 zurückkehrt und
zwar auf verpflichtender Basis denn der
Versuch der Freiwilligkeit ist
erwiesenermaßen Gesche
daher hoffen wir dass in dem anstehenden
Wahljahr möglichst viele politische
Parteien sich dieser Argumentation
anschließen aber mehr als hoffen würde
ich sagen erwarten wir dass es dazu zu
dieser Frage in einem zukünftigen
Regierungsprogramm ganz klare Antworten
gibt diese Botschaft richtet sich an die
Damen und Herren in der Politik aber
natürlich an uns alle weil wir ja als
Wähler da auch ganz entscheidend mit
Gestalten in diesem
Sinne setze ich viel Hoffnung in das
kommende
Jahr Blicke schon voraus und lade Sie
ein am 20 jänar 2025 am 12 Tag der
werrpflicht teilzunehmen aber ehe das
ist beenden wir den 11 Tag der
whrpflicht ordnungsgemäß und würdig mit
der österreichischen bundeshümne und ich
darf Sie bitten sich von den Plätzen zu
[Musik]
Zuben
[Applaus]
[Musik]